kourtney kardashian and travis barker
practiced their i do's over the weekend
in an unofficial las vegas wedding
ceremony about 12 30
on i guess monday morning i got a call
that a celebrity wanted to get married
they didn't tell me who it was they just
said it's celebrity
and we need elvis now the 42 year old
reality star is giving fans an inside
look and you best believe it's the
definition of rock and roll they were
just falling in love they were just
kissing and
laughing it's fun just fun and they're
in love
and they're just smiling and they left
happy on wednesday court shared these
snaps on instagram the pooch founder and
the 46 year old blink 182 drummer posted
up rocking matching black leather
jackets fort holding a bouquet of red
roses in front of an elvis officiant
doing what they do best pda people they
dance right here they dance they kiss
and they got married and they were
singing and just dancing court captioned
the post writing in part quote once upon
a time in a land far far away las vegas
at 2am after an epic night and a little
tequila a queen and her handsome king
ventured out to the only open chapel
with an elvis and got married with no
license practice makes perfect
they did vows they did a lot of kissing
and dancing while they were standing
about after that they went
took the fresh roses
out front and did the bouquet toss
and they left naturally court's friends
and family slid into the comments kim
kardashian with four chapel emojis lala
anthony with four heart eye emojis while
court's pal simon huck asked quote who
doesn't love a vegas dress rehearsal it
was beautiful amazing like court said
the vegas elopement didn't legally bind
her and travis since they didn't get a
marriage license but a source previously
told et that the lovebirds hit up the
chapel after the grammy awards on sunday
night calling it a somewhat spontaneous
thing ahead of their actual wedding this
spring the source adds that travis
thought it would be fun and cute to
commemorate their relationship this way
quote courtney is so in love with travis
and is down to do anything he's into
travis loves to flaunt their love and
can't wait to spend the rest of his life
with courtney i love you
and according to e.t source courtney is
so happy they're both very excited to
keep celebrating together and to honor
their love with their friends and family
[Music]
you